So the question is,
how good is this function that we build
in order to do the classification?
And you can't really answer that and
tell me,
until you tell me what good means,
all right?
And what good means, two things.
First of all, what kinds of
mistakes does our classifier make?
All right?
And for each of those mistakes, sort of,
how expensive is it to
make those mistakes?
And when we build
a supervised classifier,
or supervised classification, since we
know what the desired outputs are for
a given set and then we can run
the thing as we're designing it, what we
want to do is we want to minimize
the expected misclassification cost.
Okay?
We want to make mistakes
as infrequently as possible.
And the more expensive the mistake is
the less often we want to make that
particular mistake.
All right, to do this,
to handle classification,
there are two general strategies.
The first method, which is referred to
as generative, you basically use your
training data from class A to
build a model of class A.
Separately, you build a model of class
B, you build a model of class c,
you build a model of class d.
And then when you're
given a new example,
you say well does model A explain
it better, or model B, or model C.
Whichever one explains it better,
that's my, that's the one I pick.
And it's referred to as generative
because the idea is that I have a model
that describes sort of all the different
possible things that would be
of class A.
At least, that's the hope.
Or you could even think of it as
generating a set of examples that
are class A.
The other way of doing it,
is referred to as discriminative.
Discriminative says, well, here's A, and
here's a bunch of things that are not A,
and let me learn how to
discriminate between them.
Okay?
So
I'm not going to worry about
modeling what all of A is.
What I want to do is,
if I only have As, Bs, and Cs,
I have to look at how would I
discriminate between A or Bs and Cs?
Or I could also do A versus B,
A versus C, B versus C and, and, and
learn those, but the discriminative,
the discriminative approach
focuses on learning the boundary,
the separator between our categories.
Today what we're going to be doing
is talking about generative, and
then we'll move on to discriminative
in a couple of future lessons.